Сімейний лікар на Одещині уклав декларації
з майже тисячею восьмистами пацієнтами
й отримав в липні втричі більше, ніж раніше -
понад шістнадцять тисяч гривень.
Твітер-акаунт прем’єр-міністра України Володимира Гройсмана
рясніє такими прикладами збільшення зарплат медиків,
з хештегом "медична реформа в дії". Втім, не в усіх областях
і медзакладах ситуація така сама.
Медична реформа передбачає, що держава платить медзакладам
за безпосередньо надані послуги, а не просто за ліжко-місце.
Для цього лікарі цих закладів мають укладати декларації з пацієнтами.
За кожного дорослого пацієнта держава платить від 370
до 740 гривень, залежно від віку пацієнта.
Однак, важливий нюанс полягає в тому,
що гроші йдуть не напряму лікарю, а медзакладу.
А отримати ці гроші медзаклад може виключно,
якщо уклав договір з Національною службою здоров’я.
Станом на зараз з понад 1200 лікарень
лише десята частина уклали такі договори - 161 лыкарня.
Тобто про підвищення зарплат в більшості медзакдалів поки не йдеться.
Згідно зі статистикою МОЗу, найбільше фінансування
отримали заклади первинної медичної допомоги у Києві,
Полтавській, Вінницькій та Дніпропетровській областях.
І саме про збільшення зарплат там і звітують в МОЗ,
а потім про це пише у соцмережах прем’єр-міністр.
Очікувано, що саме у столиці найбільше закладів,
що підписали договори з Нацслужбою здоров’я - 28.
А в сусідній Чернігівській області - лише один заклад.
Навіть у Львівській, Закарпатській, Чернівецькій
та Кіровоградській областях - по 1-2 заклади.
Про зарплати медиків в цих областях ані МОЗ, ані прем’єр Гройсман поки не звітують.
Причина, чому так мало закладів нині
уклали договори з Нацслужбою, проста.
Згідно з процедурою, спершу медзаклад має перетворитися
з бюджетної установи на комунальне некомерційне підприємство.
А цим має займатися місцева влада,
яка подекуди умисно чи з об’єктивних причин гальмує процес.
Втім, як повідомили DW в Нацслужбі здоров’я,
в другій хвилі укладання договорів
більше 400 медзакладів країни можуть приєднатися до медреформи.
Однак навіть після укладання медзакладом договору
нема гарантії, що зарплата лікаря в усіх регіонах значно збільшиться.
Наприклад, у МОЗ стверджують, що чим більше декларацій
лікар укладе з пацієнтами, тим більше він отримуватиме.
Втім, насправді, ані МОЗ, ані Нацслужба здоров’я
не можуть впливати на зарплати лікарів
і не можуть їх контролювати. Немає встановленого законом
відсотка, який має отримувати лікар від коштів,
виділених державою на пацієнта медзакладу.
В кожній лікарні самі визначають цей відсоток -
він може бути і 20-30%, а може бути і менше.
Наприклад, згідно з даними МОЗ, якщо лікар на Одещині отримує
понад 16000 гривень за 1795 пацієнтів
то такий самий лікар на Донеччині
за 1800 пацієнтів отримує 10000  гривень.
У МОЗ пояснюють, що конкуренція і ринкові закони
змусять керівництво лікарень підвищувати зарплати,
щоб утримати гарних медиків.
Утім не в усіх містах у медиків є можливість
перейти в іншу лікарню
або переїхати в інший регіон у пошуках більшої зарплати.